okay so we have like
yesterday i don't i don't care which
version you do
okay but from here contact
keep contact where it is so if you want
to try to stand that vote
you i'm going to go around his head
can you see how i bring my body to the
arm okay
and his elbow's going to join me and
then i'm going to push down
on his elbow he's going to turn over
and then i have nico
boom contact bring my body to it
then start to push down
[Music]
boom
so
not gonna like it no sensei always said
if i have to move you it's gonna hurt
okay but if he doesn't move i'll
i will move him i'm ready to move him
okay
more and more i'm going to reduce how
much i move around
you see
so the beginning the pattern is not
intuitive
i find beginners always want to take the
arm this way
but this arm is going this way
so here body to it
start to push down once you understand
the patterns
you don't have to move much at all it's
on
[Music]
boom
okay hey
you have to look ahead on the cycle of
action
okay it's very very common
in aikido jiu jitsu in general
you do not paint the picture
like you took a snapshot of the ending
it's how you got there that's everything
okay if you try to paint what you last
saw
you'll almost always do it wrong okay
so we're gonna use a different example
okay so uh when i attack that arm that
arm is straight
you see i have to picture
the kimura that i'm going to have at the
end
it's not a straight arm so if i come
here
and i go straight you're picturing
yourself
you're not going to get the kimura but
you think you have something here do you
see that
like he's gonna be strong okay
so if he's in maneuver don't let me even
take you down
so i have to paint the arm
the whole picture and i end up there
so when i come around boom
this move goes this way you see now i
have to bend
now i come around and same thing so i'm
going to start pushing here
but i'm going to move myself you see
and then i now have the camera
i'm gonna just move out let me know you
stay there
go put your butt down put down
same technique you see
so when we do the maneuver
i have to look ahead
what you're trying to do is go like this
and be strong no you're not
okay you have to do the same thing
i'm not going here i'm gonna go
body to the arm and i'm gonna turn
you see i'm doing that it's starting to
look already like the ending
i just need him to lay down no no
okay that's why i dropped my weight
elbow goes down
in the final lock you see
it's already on isn't it
what you guys do is laying down give me
that same one
he's laying down
is your uk always rolls over for you
and then they wait for you
you get to go like that
the lock must be on
it's all i i already have it i already
have it
okay it's on i'm just turning
boom
okay you see that difference okay
so uh you see how he's scrambling
because there ain't no way it's either
going to come off
or he's going to take the camera so what
you could do
as okay is
uh you don't have to roll over
do you know what i mean if you
you have the habit of rolling yourself
over
and now because technique is never
tested
you get to have that technical deviation
everything works
so everything looks like it will work so
it doesn't matter
what you do but that's not true
it's not true one is mechanically sound
one is tactically sound and then a whole
bunch of [\h__\h] is not
okay so if you have to do a two a two
move
lock it ain't [\h__\h] working
okay if they have to roll over for you
it's not working okay
so what i'm saying is okay
don't roll yourself over unless you feel
your shoulder about to be ripped off
okay get out of the choreograph
roll over i saw the roll he did you see
him
right it's like a fish out of water so
i'm not going to go
fast because i don't want to injure him
but you have to move do you see that
just like
in the kimura from the closed guard
he has to move he's got no choice
there's no choice
okay so let's try to sharpen this up
more marshall please does it means
faster
yeah so uh
work this basic i don't want to
have this space between my body and the
arm right
i'm going to bring my body is going to
attack that arm you see it's
no space for yourself on my chest okay
same thing here one
this arm has done its job
so after it's done its job it moves to
the next
tactical priority which is
the grip here i don't want it coming up
okay do you see this face get rid of
this
this arm does not move it's already
seeing the next technique
okay so i now just
turn my body around the arm
don't do this out here
see i came off and you're going to go
back on
hug the arm
[Music]
it's on boom
next point if i do that his elbow
is ahead on the pistol
okay so this elbow goes to the final
spot
of the kimura or the nico pin
which is on the front side of my spine
so i go
one it's already there don't have it
over here
put it there then you start turning
around it and you see it's in position
so it's not over here
so that's your marker one
body put it on the front side of your
spine
then start going around the arm
okay let's try it what were you tall at
the beginning
kind of feel free to walk around
because the pattern is not intuitive
over the decades of teaching
i've just seen so many students try to
paint the ending
try to do the obvious okay move the arm
in a way that's mechanically inferior
okay but then
you were told you shouldn't have to move
at all
do you remember that because if you now
have to do it
in two moves and that's not going to be
marshall
okay it should be in one move it goes
right from the throw
right into the movement okay so uh
you know and you don't have to go fast
to do that you just
are constantly thinking ahead so i'm
already picturing what i'm gonna do with
that arm
so i'm already picturing that elbow
going onto this hip
do you see that so as we come around
boom
it's in place you see
do you see how i did that hey you don't
have to go fast but what i'm trying to
say
is your boot is disconnected so you have
this space
you see okay then you gotta do the other
way you're gonna
bring your body to it
okay but now what some of you are doing
is still the
i brought my body there but i'm moving
like this
you see what were you supposed to do
here go around it
just like the closed guard one you go
around the arm
you don't paint the picture you see
you're bringing it like that and then
and then that's not marshall okay you
got it
all right so let's try it again
try not to have to walk go
[Music]
because it's not gonna work
you're not gonna be able to roll me over
that way go i'll show you what you want
go see how you're pulling me there you
see that
you want to try to get over this ledge
but this ledge is on that side of this
point of no return this center of
gravity
and then you have the friction of my
other arm
and without strength you can't overcome
the friction
or the weight so what what you're trying
to do is
use the bottom ribcage as your focal
point
and make this go over that way so i'm
going to show you what you're going to
see this part
you're trying to make it go like this
okay so she goes
she's going like this do you see
but that's a lot of weight she has to
lift that
and she has to overcome this friction
here and
go ahead and you're just not gonna do it
okay so go back and i'll just give you a
little bit of
muscle of a resistant person okay you go
do you understand so it looks
it looks but we're doing something
different okay
so i'm already picturing this elbow
going here okay so as i throw
i make that elbow boom right there
you see so i'm going to show you you
first you're trying to go
over you see and i'm not going to move
you see the difference okay you got it
if you're trying to roll over somebody
you're gonna have to be way stronger
than them okay
i am basically this technique is
happening on a radius
around the shoulder just just like the
camera from the closed guard
okay try to hit it